[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hi how
are y'all could not be better what's
up so our situation I have a 23-year-old
stepson that's on his second senior year
two more senior years left to go to get
a general business
degree and my husband pays tuition rent
utilities truck
everything for him
so when he does graduate he has stated
that he doesn't want to get a job he
doesn't want to be an adult you know
doesn't
want to do anything except for basically
live off my husband Lonnie Lonnie Lonnie
why in the world would he want to get a
job he has it made he's got the perfect
life exactly well that's what I tell my
husband I'm like why would he if you're
going to pay for everything I mean well
it's not the it's not the paying for
everything some people are able to bless
their kids that's fine it's the um it's
the way in which that blessing is
becoming a
curse that's what I'm I'm thinking um
there's no accountability with it it's
it's an ATM machine with an endless
donor yes and I'm on board with paying
for tuition for his school I feel like
after 5 years we should stop and if he
needs two more years because he messed
around and lived his best life for a few
years I feel like that should be on him
that we shouldn't be on the hook you
know seven years for a general business
bachelor's degree hey Lonnie your
conversation is not with your with this
your stepson your conversation is with
your
husband yes and he is not on board but
here's here's what hold on don't miss
what I'm trying to say
your anger and frustration should be
with your husband and you are not you're
refusing to to have that interaction and
so you're deflecting it on this 23y old
kid it's not the 23y old kid's fault
he's just been doing exactly what life
has presented
him as my friend Henry Cloud says he
needs some problems like rent and truck
payments and insurance but he's never
had those because of your husband not
because of something that's wrong with
your 3y
old right so how do I try to get my
husband on board because you know I've
had the
discussion many times and his response
is you know it's my money I can do
whatever I want you know if we want to
pay that's one problem this idea that
it's all my money and so you don't get a
vote in what I do with my
money the other problem is it sounds
like he's been trying to buy his son's
love for a long time now and if he
doesn't have this anymore the
relationship will need some actual uh
repair yes that is true so that's what's
lying underneath all this that I can
smell a mile away but the conversation
he needs to have with his son is hey
I've been doing a really terrible job
raising you into the man that I want you
to be and that you need to be and so
this looks like new boundaries new rules
as for what how this is going to happen
you're going to finish school in 2 years
or else I'm not paying for it you're
going to now take over the truck payment
and get a part-time job and guess what
the son's not going to like that is he
no but that's between them at that point
isn't
it yes that's you need to put the ball
back in his court and he needs to be a
man and be a husband and it needs to be
our money which means you get a vote
that's what he signed up for when he
married you isn't it yes that is correct
so here's the conversation it is not I
can't believe you're giving this kid
money I can't can't believe you're doing
that you know you're doing this you know
you're doing this cuz when you come at
him with a bunch of accusations he has
to defend himself that's just human
nature he doesn't have to he could curl
up in a ball but he's got to defend
himself and if you can look back at your
series of actions they haven't worked
have they it's just nagging him about
this working no it's not so let's do
something different let's take him out
how long have youall been
married um two years okay let's take him
out and say two years ago we both said I
do
and my money and my heart and my life
became yours and your money and your
life and your heart became
mine and when you say things like it's
my money I can do whatever I
want it scares me to death and I can't
breathe because I feel like I'm hanging
out here all by myself like you're
renting
me and it either has to be all of us or
we have to have a much harder
conversation because two years into
marriage this isn't a marriage this is
just a a really sophisticated roommate
situation you see how one is you telling
him how you feel how scared you are how
his actions affect you and the other is
you just nagging him and throwing things
at
him one is an invitation to a
conversation a hard one the other is I'm
throwing stuff at you I'm going to throw
stuff at you throw stuff at you and then
you get mad and walk
away third or fourth down the list we'll
get to talking about how he's funding
his son's
immaturity with no end in
sight but that's not the first
conversation the first conversation is
your marriage is not as strong as you
think it is and let's be super honest
there's other things going on besides
this isn't it isn't
there no actually we have a wonderful
marriage it's just this is the only
that we argue
about you just described a way in which
it's not
wonderful and that is he has his stuff
and you've got
yours which means you'll have a
wonderful living Arrangement you don't
have a wonderful
marriage because wonderful marriage says
who are we going to be
together and how are we going to move
forward completely United getting closer
with every step we take into the future
not this is my crap and that's your
crap see what I'm
saying
yes that's the hard conversation to have
do you have a good relationship with him
with the
stepson um not really because we we
you're trying to ruin his life make him
pay for his own truck no we all we only
see him when he wants money or need
something from my husband no oh really
right I mean I think you try to invest
in this relationship and you try to help
him set some goals and dig in and make
it more than just a transaction oh I
like that idea George maybe you call him
and take him to
Coffee there's an option maybe you call
him and say hey I just wanted to get to
know you better what if we started going
lunch together I'll cover lunch there
you go yeah I'll pay for lunch hey uh
marriage is not um you do yours and I'll
do mine it's we will do ours however
complicated that is